you
[Applause]
quandary quandary Nina Yamato a la
pareja Mikasa when I was a little girl I
used to draw on all the walls of my
house
Azteca near me Moreno ha Mary ho
well here una parade there are no boy
ray allahumma Piraeus until one day my
mother got angry and told me you can
only draw on one wall
don't draw on any others edition TV
primeira actors in surah totalitarian
that was the first time I experienced an
act of totalitarian censorship pero la
falta Libertad esta muy elegante yacht
Elettra potentia allen finito but a lack
of freedom stimulates creativity and
empowers it a empezar muchos anos a soon
pass a premiere to you for male siempre
johan de clase yaga universidad estudio
para mo para mi necesita comunicación
lastly Torah en el aula pero lo único
que me connect a mere persona con la
vida a poder de hablar many years have
passed since my childhood but throughout
my formal studies I found myself drawing
in the margins of my notebooks instead
of paying attention to my professors I
studied journalism in college with the
intention of expanding my communication
and writing skills but the only thing
that I felt connected to in life was
drawing your nasty and democracia
Gangubai easy Amaro Venezuela cattlemen
tonight Dada I was born into democracy
in the country called Venezuela which is
now a dictatorship Yahoo hey lauryn tu
no eres una Calicut or a diarrhea em you
know los mejores periodico de Venezuela
me gusta wat reducir la condesa
the REO India hos tanto politico's como
su cialis for 19 years
I was the daily cartoonist for a
universal one of the biggest newspapers
in Venezuela
I really enjoyed translating political
and cultural current events into
drawings en la Nova Catorce MSP Aaron
Demetria hope o una caricature Acapulco
a Lucia a la salud in Venezuela yonder
suit el estaba la fere male chavez como
eco no principal in the year 2014 I got
fired from my job at the newspaper over
a card
to that I draw alluding to the health
care system in Venezuela I do a flat
line of a heartbeat monitor but I
intentionally drew the heartbeat line in
a way that resembled the signature of
Hugo Chavez the former president of
Venezuela
totaku rio a special periodic of a
comprar Borinquen socio Fantasma elk
while ago you know sort of PN circa for
gobierno all this happened after the
newspaper was bought by an unknown
company and some of us suspect that it
was the Venezuelan government who was
behind that deal
the caricature so Leo muy mal esto para
la Ligue de hora you know supporting a
la la libertad ratio heeelp si mean to
leave early my work as a cartoonist
became more and more of a nuisance for
the dictatorship they have no tolerance
for any freedom of expression or
free-thinking displeasure my appeal
m-pesa sentiment peligro mi propio Pais
yamaja no Nima's a - oh hey Marty
he somet amento Locarno public on a
canal de televisión del estado novo
legal on a salir de Venezuela yet well
meant a we won last year Miami semi pro
petal and LeWeb after I got fired
I started to feel unsafe in my own
country I received anonymous calls and
death threats
I was marked publicly on national
television I was eventually forced out
of Venezuela and I now live in Miami
Florida where I'm free to be my own
editor for my work la cara cateura
altaïr momento la libertad un país por
ESO logic tours
Odia melaka rica turistas he tratan de
Redick arvasu espacio todo lo que tenga
que ver con el amor como fa ho soceity
a political cartoon is a barometer of
freedom in a country that's why
dictators hate cartoonists and try to
eradicate everything that involves humor
as a mirror for social and political
issues la cara cateura juego de deus que
c'est combien de vous hos
yakumo resulta la violación de algo
quilt Oh a cartoon involves the delicate
balance of ideas and drawings that
reveal a hidden truth la Calicut hora
Buena es la cuenta toda la película so
la cual and a good cartoon is one that
conveys the plot of a full-length movie
in a single frame
caricature of a punt our centro de la
dianna para expresar su potentiel we
swallow SU poder en el mensaje SE como
su efecto en applicable docetic
astronomy and to leave a Kahuna
halitosis a cartoon needs to communicate
the core of a story with its precision
and when it succeeds its message can
have the effect of inoculating people
with the dose of skepticism at Calicut
horas en neutral observation el analysis
superior Kumu Sahel Antigua dad mo a los
clásico him Adorno's en algunos casos
Palaeolithic o--'s llamo entrance que
llamas moderna pasar el mundo toen
parado siempre stallion all cartoons are
drawn from observation and analysis they
are inspired by muses of mythology as
well as classical modern and Paleolithic
tales when we are when we are told that
a modern-day Emperor is wearing new
clothes
cartoons reveal that the Emperor just
might still be naked un tiempo en Paseo
har muchos Erica Masseria trabajo los
compare a con los political hero who are
a nacionales kayra premiere
manifestation s Pacifica hello
estudiantes India a yerim efficient on
el periódico consiguió una Carta Amy
Metro at one point in my career I drew
pigs and compare them with politicians
and national guards who were responsible
for stopping peaceful student
demonstrations one day when I got back
to my office I had a letter on my desk
Adriana Caracalla Federation - Alana a
posse cultura the letter was from the
Venezuelan swine Federation la carta ACA
por favor no compara dong-won email
tomorrow your supervisor
full of political Raquel Seohyun email
Mui Amiga a simpatico normally que puede
llegar a ser una buena miqo'te he del
cual supporting a lament era muchos
approach and a salute amended Toa
souvenir Ashiya the letter said please
do not compare an animal as wonderful as
a pig with politicians pigs are very
friendly and noble they can be a great
mascot they make good pets and they
provide sustenance to us in the form of
pork being sold Athenian toilet a song
nor hey masseur Hospital see much of my
politics I think they were absolutely
right I didn't draw any more pigs but I
did keep drawing politicians octoly
Mandela caricature a via a piloto pistol
información L'Aquila para entertainer
multiple Canales through toe head under
here por la mia TCL calculon REO me
gusta no me gusta son la única opciones
kale actually aware Nile pensamiento mo
karate Colella web a cartoon travels on
an information Highway which seems like
it has multiple lanes but in reality all
these lanes lead to a binary response of
either positivity or rage I like it or I
don't like it those are the only
responses that govern democratic
thinking on the Internet
hemos perdido en s paso de carrera
argument OHS no tenemos tiempo
simplemente octo ammos for en contra una
Co dos solo para for a serum algorithm
oh we have lost space for nuanced debate
we have no time so we simply respond
with approval or disdain and we let
algorithms take over la cara catherine
hace unas paseo de pensamiento plural
por ESO el tariqa turista parse a su
propio esta vez para do hari producer
embedded Aeroport a graphic o-laca iike
to respond espacio para Henare of dia
logos no confrontation but a cartoon is
born from a space of deep nuanced
thinking creating a good cartoon
involves repeated failures Draft after
draft and a cartoonist must shed their
own taboos to spark a conversation
rather than a confrontation through
their work en el ano of mystery say Moo
do el Presidente
Chow's am i Madoka Harlock Erica Torah
Aliya siguiente case a public area al
periodico yo estaba muy Feliz por esta
muerto pensaba que la really word on
Tobias nickel of tiempos Kevin Ryan said
I am a facility para dolls in the year
2013 President Chavez died and I had to
think about what to draw as the cartoon
of the day latterly that self I was
personally happy that he had passed away
because I thought that the end of his
power would potentially bring our
country closer to freedom in better
times pero hay Mucha gente que euro a la
muerte choice
abbiamo ambiente piously video una
Celeron yo hiramasa leader but there
were many other people who were mourning
the death of Chavez so there was a
divided sentiment in Venezuela some were
celebrating and others were crying at
the loss of their leader yo sabía que
dibujar aro momento historic oh no podía
permit ear kami felicidade filter ara mi
trabajo de via le VAR el mensaje respite
are a Lulu Cindy have a serious mi
trabajo que pollyali woo ha I felt stuck
I really didn't know what to draw on
this historic moment and I knew that I
couldn't allow my happiness to seep into
my work that I should take the higher
Road and respect people's grief so what
could I draw passe muchas horas de Hondo
yacht and opop Ellis mater mia mama todo
está detrás on la pagina head periodico
para un instante la noche y a goal idea
yeah fue cuando public a esta Krakatoa
que trabajo el acontecer de una so
Sierra I spent many hours drafting and
throwing out papers my editor called me
and said everything was late for that
day's newspaper and asked me when I'd be
done it was in the middle of the night
that the idea came to me and we then
published a cartoon that represented a
historical moment in time ray the head
race oh ho chi yo a fallen king chess
piece in red la cara cateura
f potent ensue resultados where Henner
are accion erection s por eso que sera
have circled soluta responsibili pero
simmias
alla consequences a good cartoon has a
lot of power
it can generate action and reaction
that's why a cartoonist must exercise
the power responsibly showcasing the
truth and drawing without the fear of
consequences Lapine young teen un precio
and alguna physis yeah muy Alto having
an opinion has a cost and in some
countries that cost is high in Venezuela
mucho holiness can see also see now
protests are Pacifica mint
Tommy Andres Imahara sprays of political
director Tao will have lows Mucha
mujeres que la Brisa
para que ser para que no se a Vida poor
sook ammonia in Venezuela many young
people have been killed for protesting
peacefully there are men and women who
are stuck behind bars as political
prisoners so over the years I've drawn
the faces of imprisoned women because I
don't want them to be forgotten by the
community este año nuevo en todo el
foldo Pinal una Copa seondeok assisted
with a mental press of Politico in
Venezuela same answer kana muchacha
Emery ho just to oppressor he to me o
hasta yo ha stem Astoria he Mucha gente
subbu Canario es mi y mucho a surveyor
of la vieja Carson
muchas gracias this year an event called
el faro panel which is a criminal forum
where a group of lawyers do pro bono
work for Venezuelan political prisoners
a young woman approached me and she said
I was imprisoned and then you drew my
face and my story it's because of that
drawing that people knew who I was your
cartoon helped me survive my days in
prison
thank you after hi yo Kim allegro mucho
the Karuna capacity' para que la verdad
que la memoria mi país é isso gente this
was a moment that meant a lot to me
because I had found a way to collaborate
with the memories in my country and its
people el año pasado m-pesa do her solo
el tema la mere ocean Devo hava me
propio mundo mimi-rose Mimolette Emilio
por la parada LRA go todo lo que me
tokoha atras mi mismo mi Pais también la
alegría friend esta oportunidad como mi
grande en los Estados Unidos last year I
started making drawings about
immigration I drew my own world
my fears my suitcase my roots and
everything that I had to leave behind in
Venezuela I also drew my joy in the face
of this new opportunity
as an immigrant in the United States
yagi Salinas area hosts Emma Tico's
carry crayon Lhasa colonial immigration
from there I worked on a series of
drawings that represented the experience
and psychology of immigration Sarah
immigrant Eskimo Yeager Otto Planeta
initial mentor no entiendo
nah no mundo que rodea no F Cody goes my
of idioma hasta necesitan mechanism
artificially poor adapt arte Astana Vida
being an immigrant is like moving to
another planet at first you don't
understand anything about your new world
there are new codes and new language and
unfamiliar tools you need to learn how
to use in order to adapt to your new
life said immigrant a new math pareció
sir wha turn out okay Teresa in la Luna
being an immigrant is the closest thing
to being an astronaut who landed on the
moon como el tiempo hace lo hace una
posición me Tina Dante Yamada yo
immigrant a yes position yeah we have
our yes you guys como Miami
Houston Madrid Barcelona if paramo here
are la muchos Gracias over time that
series of drawings became a traveling
exhibition called I immigrant and the
exhibition traveled to multiple cities
including Miami Houston Madrid Barcelona
and we're hoping for more places haneda
una zona encuentro para la diaspora
yay reconocimiento eleemosynary a que su
3 most all immigrant ease the show has
become a meeting space for the Diaspora
for people to gather and recognize their
shared experiences of suffering that
come with immigration Macari kotora
pretend a alert are so ello significant
immigrant a know a hungry minal
immigrant es una persona Cara Yolo
general una familia que hace obliga hace
para our save-a-ho condiciones in
amana's yob ligado a marcharse a soup
ice in busca el mejor recognition havea
what I want these drawings to convey is
that an immigrant is not a criminal an
immigrant is a person
life has been broken a person who has
very likely been separated from their
family under inhumane conditions who has
been forced to leave their country in
search of a better life
oonh do hope Weser la cinta CL universal
de un país de una sociedad Oh de la
manera pensar de un individual do her
Calicut urahara me
una forma de resistance a drawing can be
a synthesis of a place a universe a
country or a society it can also
represent the inner workings of
someone's mind for me
giant cartoons is a form of resistance
la carrera que tu de una pierna Rosetta
que cela ransom Hollis Posse O'Hara
dentro algunos Sano's la cerveza de
quien esta plan Delta C exists yo el
pensamiento Lyrae el mundo Sevilla saw a
cartoon is like a rosetta stone if we
throw it into outer space a future alien
would be able to know with certainty
that in the past we once had a civilized
world with free thinking es por ESO que
la paired k-mer a la la mia madre a he
finita Yahoo la si go debo Hondo that
one wall that my mother gave me the
freedom to draw and feels infinite and
it's for that reason that I am so
drawing thank you very much
[Applause]